previous videos we've talked a little
bit about distance traveled versus
displacement what i'm going to do in
this video is discuss it on a
one-dimensional number line
and we'll get a little bit more mathy in
this video
so here is my number line and let's say
that this is 0
4 and it keeps going on and then in the
negative direction negative 1
negative 2
and negative three
and let's say
that i start off
with a lemon
let's say my lemon starts off right over
here at zero on my number line
and let's say it first moves two to the
right
so it first moves two to the right i'll
denote that by plus two
and then from there it moves three to
the left
so then it moves three to the left and i
will use negative for the left so it
moves three to the left
and then let's say that it then
moves
another
one to the left
so then it goes another one to the left
and i'll denote negative one as moving
one to the left
so based on what we know about distance
traveled and displacement what is the
distance traveled for this dot distance
traveled pause the video and see if you
can figure that out
well remember distance traveled is the
entire path length or the entire entire
length of the dot's journey so this is
going to be equal to
2 to the right so plus 2
and then 3 to the left now this is an
important notion when we talk about
distances we want we wouldn't say
positive or negative we just care about
the absolute value of the amount that we
are traveling so we we won't specify a
direction now you might say hey where's
the direction being specified well
implicitly whether something is positive
or negative on this number line is
giving a direction but if we're talking
about distances we wouldn't pay
attention to the direction we only care
about the magnitude
so this would be two
plus three
plus one it doesn't matter if this is
one to the left or one to the right
doesn't mean it matter if it's positive
one or negative one we care about its
absolute value we care about its
magnitude so the distance traveled in
this example is going to be
6 units whatever the units are on my
number line right over here if these are
in meters and this would be 6 meters
now what is the displacement and
remember displacement is net change in
position
displace
mint what is that going to be
pause the video and see if you can
figure it out
well displacement is going to be you
could view this as equal to your final
position and we'll use x let's say this
is the x axis
so we'll say x final your final position
minus your initial position it's really
just your change in position
so what is your change in position here
well your final position is you are at
negative two at x equals negative two
and then what was your initial position
your initial position you started at
zero so negative two minus zero is equal
to negative two
so how would we visualize that on our
drawing here well we started here just
think about what is your net change in
position you started here and regardless
of what your path was you ended up
2 to the left
so your
your displacement is negative 2. now
displacement we care not just about the
magnitude we care about the magnitude
and the direction
and now so you might be saying well
where is the direction specified if i
just say negative 2
well the sign in a one-dimensional case
is giving us our direction
so the sign is giving us a direction i
start off implicitly with this notion
that negative is to the left and
positive is to the right and we're in
this one-dimensional world and those are
the only two directions that i can
travel in so if i'm in this
one-dimensional world or if i'm if i'm
thinking about just one dimension the
sign gives me my direction so that's why
displacement where i care about the
magnitude and the direction i do care
about the sign
while distance where i only care about
the magnitude i don't care about the
sign so i just keep adding up the
magnitudes while over here another way
you could think about it you first get
displaced by 2 to the right so that's
plus 2 the plus says to the right
then you get displaced by 3 to the left
so that is minus three and then you get
displaced by one to the left again so
that's minus one that's why we we're
talking about displacement that's why we
care about the sign and if you were to
add all of these together you are going
to get a net displacement of negative 2.
but an easier way was just what's your
final position
minus your initial position